hi my name is Jeremy Michaelson and I'm
going to help Alan Joyce present the new
text to natural language functionality
in version 11 I don't think I have a lot
of time so I'm going to go pretty quick
but we'll leave behind the slides for
you to study
in version 11 we have more ways of
constructing strings extracting from
strings and otherwise manipulating
strings we have new functions for
analyzing and transforming text we have
data about languages in words and we
have ways for you to implement your own
text parsing including hooks into
Wolfram Alpha
natural language parsing since version
10 point O is released we've introduced
new and enhanced string manipulation
functions and one of the favorites a
string riffle as a way to take a list of
strings and concatenate them using a
common joiner it also works with higher
rank arrays as you see here and even
different the limiters for the different
depths
insert loin brakes can be used to
reformat text so here's the nicely
reformatted text string partition is a
nice way to group text into clumps in
the same way that partition does and so
here we can see it grabbing the triples
from a DNA string and that works in
exactly the same way that partition does
and then we have other functions like
string parts to extract particular
characters from a string string delete
to delete from the sub strings that
match a pattern and so on you can see
that our functions aren't restricted
just to English we also have data about
characters themselves so you can see
character name being used here to give
different kinds of information about
Unicode code points and palindrome q is
a fun function detecting palindromes and
and it works not just on strings but
also on integers
we also have new functions for finding
the grammatical unit entity associated
with a word and the definition of that
word
and moving on we also have programmatic
access to version 11s new spell
correction dictionary so the front end
has spell correction and that is now
programmatically accessible
one source of text is book data so here
you can see an analysis of the books by
Charles Dickens for example
so we've got the word counts down here
which is kind of interesting and all of
the it was the best of worst of and so
on from A Tale of Two Cities
you
we can also partition the text into
words and sentences and as well as
remove the so-called stop words such as
the and uh and other uninteresting words
like that so that's delete stop words
here and there are other interesting
functions as you can see on the slide
we have historical data about how
frequently words were used in texts
meant the given time so here's an
interesting date list plot of war and
peace
we can also selects tracked semantic
content from text for example all the
nouns here all the nouns in George
Washington's first State of the Union
and currency amounts so all the
quantities of that particular type and
so on and there's also this cool
grammatical structure capability and the
really neat thing about that is that
these things hook straight into our
graph functionality which allows
continued computation with the structure
that you get finally we have the ability
to introduce our own context-free
grammars and these piggy back on top of
the Wolfram Alpha parser so for example
we can say that we're looking for a
location preceded by the words - and a
location preceded by the word from and
then that allows us to parse something
like from New York to Chicago and get a
nice Geographic spec
thank you